[Music]
hey here we are better late than never
yeah made it back from the [ __ ] va
doctor
yeah had my eyes checked out my vision
got better
yeah it's better than it was last time i
told you that right
yeah yeah you told me that yeah i told
them it was themselves like dude man
you look you're 51 man you look [ __ ]
awesome this is
like man i'm 31 you look gross you look
better than me and i said man if i could
knock that [ __ ] off
and then was [ __ ] talking about
working out and then i
prescribed the doctors some lgd
said this is how much you take this he
says yeah i'm gonna see some results
this time
that's gonna be these results does the
audio sound okay because it sounds kind
of strange to me it might be strange i
don't know can you guys hear me
because that's why we were actually
[ __ ] with y'all we were supposed to
go
on at four but for some reason i um yeah
doesn't it sound really weird it sounds
like really echoey
yeah yeah yeah but i think it's because
um yeah i don't know yeah dude he did
say
i was a fascinating heterosexual he did
man
he did anyway uh so we got to do this uh
yeah this probably won't be too long
today because like i said i i've
debated i debated like doing uh
this is like a god that's like driving
me crazy is it because you have the
audio there
or because it's bouncing back on here
yeah it's echoing
no this this is not turned on oh okay
well the weird
yeah it's like we were gonna go on like
a bit earlier like at four
and then i was sitting here [ __ ]
around with like the obs
program you know that we used to stream
maybe
he's gonna have to turn the microphone
of the laptop off
i don't know it's really weird it says
no it says the mic is on
i don't really know what no the laptop
mic turn the laptop microphone off
you you're running two microphones at
the same time
no michael says it sounds good it does i
think maybe it's just because
it's just on my end i think yeah and
i'll just i'll fix it later but as long
as it's not coming out like sounding
weird
yeah it sounds like then that's fine
because yeah it was like all of a sudden
even though i didn't touch anything
uh on this program since yesterday
i went in there and for some reason like
all of my little videos like my intro
and my little starting soon i wasn't
getting any audio on it
so i don't and then i just went in there
and changed it like a whole bunch of
times like
from one setting to the setting where it
was originally and then it just started
working
suddenly so i don't [ __ ] know what
the hell is going on yeah that's true
story that i was saying those doctors
wanted to know what it was i took
and they were like oh man yeah because
they take [ __ ] well
you think doctors don't take [ __ ] [ __ ]
no they're just people like everybody
they take all kinds of [ __ ]
they give it to other people they're
glorified drug dealers don't they do
well yeah so it's like you know that
would be a little hypocritical for them
not to be able to like take stuff
so like i said we're just going to be
kind of brief today because it was you
know kind of
late uh so this movie i don't have a lot
to say about it
yeah i thought it was very mediocre
actually it's on
hulu and it was just one that i picked
it's called once upon a time at
christmas or something like that
yeah and um so basically
it's about a killer santa and his and a
killer mrs claus
they're serial killers and they go
around this little town
what the [ __ ] the name of the town i
can't even who cares i don't even
remember
but um you can tell very much
it's very weird because i think the
director of this is british from what i
could determine
and but a bunch of the people in the
movie are canadian
yeah and even though it's clearly
supposed to be in the united states
because everybody and they do this in
canadian movies a lot we're like
in the cops office no like in the cops
office they'll have like a huge american
flag like hanging in the back like
everywhere has american flags like the
bar has an american flag
it makes america everywhere but i'm
pretty sure i'm not sure if they shot it
in canada but a bunch of the actors
were clearly canadian because of the way
that they talked
so i don't so i don't really know what
they were trying to pull but christmas
one
christmas killer woman she had a fake
southern accent
yes yeah i kind of feel like she was
trying to be
harley quinn yeah or that maybe the two
of them were
were supposed to be like uh what's their
what's their faces from uh
joker no no no no what was the movie
with um
[ __ ] man with juliet lewis and oh the
guys from [ __ ]
uh what the [ __ ] the name of the movie
yeah got him killed
thank you i'm like oh [ __ ] man i'm
getting old i can't [ __ ] remember
anything
we didn't have a warm-up we're just
jumping on that show yeah because he's
just
that audio is [ __ ] me up that tinny
sound i know that's what i mean it's
driving me kind of crazy
yeah everybody says it sounds fine from
here okay well that's good but like i
said it's
i guess what it is it's it's the audio
is bouncing back at me
like from the laptop and it's like
really it's distracting me
because i keep there's not an echo or
anything or there's not like a delay
it's just like
let's turn the volume up down well i
don't know if that's going to make any
difference
maybe i don't really know hold on hold
on turn the speakers down
maybe see if that's better yeah okay so
maybe it was just too loud all right
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
okay i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on
we just like jumped on here so yeah so
basically this movie
is i guess this dude has made movies
before i've never seen any of them
he's like a british guy so it's this
town
there's the plot is there's just like a
santa claus and a mrs claus running
around killing people they're like
serial killers
and they're killing even like a bunch of
people at one time and they're killing
will make in weird ways
like in um you know like the mo is
different every time
yeah and it takes the cops like
half the movie to figure out what i
figured out about 20 minutes into the
movie that they're obviously
killing people thematically having to do
with the 12 days of christmas yeah
dog yeah you find a mr partridge in a
pear tree you're fine [ __ ] yourself
although they don't tell you what that
dude's name is until later because
they're cheap
six dead [ __ ] geese yes
and then like there's that like the fbi
agents come and like all of their ring
fingers like their wedding fingers are
cut off like five golden rings
and it's like it's just very funny
because takes it forever i mean it's
kind of a cool
like conceit for a serial killer but the
fact
that the cops didn't figure it out like
immediately
like as soon as the second crime
happened
um because the second crime i think was
like a couple that were making out in a
car and then they got killed in the car
and then they kept
set the car on fire but then where the
car was was
at a place called turtle dove beach or
turtledove something like that
and you'd think that somebody would have
grocked immediately that it's like oh
that's what these people are doing
you know what i'm saying so i found it
very hard and the stupid thing too is
that
the one guy who was the deputy
he went out to investigate the dead
geese issue
and i thought because he looked like oh
16 and i was like oh he finally figured
it out but then he didn't figure it out
because then like then
he went to talk to the grizzled old cop
and then it was like two or three more
murders down the line before they
[ __ ] failed
i was like i thought that was what that
face was all about that he had figured
it out back when it was six
i don't know but it's like so the thing
about this like i said it's not
it's not the worst thing i've ever seen
but um
i think that the one and a half stars
that it has like on google reviews and
rotten tomatoes is well deserved
well the thing about it is that it's not
like i watched the whole thing and it
was like
amusing but it's not bad enough
to be like it's pretty bad like not bad
enough to be a really good bad mom right
but like the acting is
you know pretty poor but not so poor
that it's
over the top and becomes hilarious again
the problem with the movie is the edit
yeah that's what it is it's not very
fast i mean it's not slow
but it's very convoluted because that's
a lot of murders that have to happen in
certain things it's just
it's just kind of a mess it wasn't it's
just kind of a mess
i mean you do get to see a bunch of
people killed in a strip club
right but it wasn't really pulling me
into anything i'm just like oh
okay yeah yeah it was just kind of there
yeah and i was just kind of like and i'm
watching it and
like i said it's competently shot yeah
but not artistic
artistically shot the acting is
bad but not so bad that you're like oh
my god that's the funniest thing ever
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like
they're just doing their jobs yeah
it's it's just like it's just on the
that side of like
cheap jack yeah but not so cheap jack
that it's like fun again
you know what i mean so it just kind of
falls in that gray area right where it's
kind of like a why bother
kind of moving yeah it's just it's just
um it's just lackluster
yeah it doesn't really have a lot of
it's it's
it's not bad it's just generic
yeah yeah i mean the only character i
really i kind of liked was like the
grizzled old cop
yeah because but you could call every
single thing like he was sitting at his
desk and i was making like kind of
mst style rips through the whole thing
and i'm sitting there going
man i sure could use a drink right now
and then he looked down at the drawer
i'm like i bet there's
booze in there and he open it there's
like a big bottle of jmb or something
like that i'm like yep
told you there it is it's not
storytelling that's the problem
yeah every you know everything was just
like very very cliched and it was just
kind of like
like i said i did like and i think that
there could be what are you doing poking
she's trying to
leave those books alone you are so crazy
she's trying to leave those books alone
hey mr turner ready like she did like
like i caught her doing something
embarrassing
[Laughter]
don't do it she has she has a thing
where if you catch her doing
something that she's not supposed to do
she will immediately like kind of go
over here
and then look at you like you totally
did not even see that yeah you know what
i mean she does that kind of [ __ ]
if she goes outside and she goes
somewhere where she's not supposed to go
like where she knows she's not supposed
to go because she's pretty good about
that
but if you go out there and catch her
somewhere she's not supposed to be she
immediately runs back to the house
and then rolls around on the porch like
right by the back door going look i've
been here the whole time yeah like
you didn't see me over there she tries
to play it off
it was just your imagination it's
[ __ ] funny
it's just your imagination oracle said
jenny sang it before i could type it hey
pookie leave some books she's over there
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up
but yeah so like i said yeah i can't
really recommend this movie because it
was kind of
it's just kind of i watched it and it
was fine but it was like
not that great and it was a little bit
annoying especially that
the the chick that played the mrs claus
like that
accent that she had because you could
tell she was trying to be harley quinn
but not really she had a southern accent
you know being southern we
know the real ones from the fake ones it
was kind of like uh
mid to late 1800s virginia nobody talks
like that anymore that's
you know yeah i haven't heard anyone
talking like that yeah
unless they were trying to do something
like in a bad period piece yeah
and a lot of times well a lot of times
that actually did speak
people that actually did speak like that
in the south they were like carpetbagger
families
they weren't really from the south they
they moved in the south to run it
they were trying to like put on they
were like our lords like our feudal
lords
you know we were their peasants that's
basically what it was like
tammy said it was some other stub tail
gray cat yeah right
yeah that's what she does she's like the
only one or she's she thinks she's real
slick
i mean she's really smart but she
doesn't understand that like we can see
her and that we're kind of smarter than
her but
but she's pretty smart though i have to
say but yeah so like i said i kind of
saved
what i knew were probably better
christmas horror movies for next week
because it was closer to christmas
so like i said this one i'm just i don't
really think it's worth
the time or the effort like to watch it
unless you're really really really bored
and just are going through all the
christmas horror because there's so many
better
christmas horror ones there's so many
better christmas horror movies
i mean i like the idea of a killer doing
the 12 days of christmas like that was
the only thing that i liked about it
like i liked but but everything was just
too on the nose
some of the cast was trying to do trying
you know the the the one that was trying
to be like harley quinn she was hot
you know yeah she was hot but you know
but it's just it was
it's it's the it's it was the edit and
the the script and the storytelling it
just
it wasn't quite artistic enough it's it
wasn't really storytelling it was just
kind of like let's
let's get this done this happens and
this is very blocky feeling and
yeah that's a good way of putting it not
that didn't really have a good flow
to it and uh it wasn't really
interesting that was the problem with it
wasn't really all that and it was like i
guess because the filmmaker was british
like i said i don't know where the [ __ ]
they filmed this
even though like a bunch of the accents
were canadian
and then some of them seemed like
american like generic and then like the
killer santa
was inexplicably british yeah and he had
like a whole mouthful of silver teeth
which they actually did explain later on
but um yeah so it was just kind of a
thing where it's like oh this girl got
killed when she was swimming by herself
in a swimming pool like at night which
why the [ __ ] would you do that i don't
really know like at a gym or a
center or something and um then
i guess because there weren't six people
because six swans are swimming right
yeah
i can't remember the song but um so
there was only one girl in there so it's
like oh well her last name was swan
and then the killer made like all these
origami swans that he left like next to
the pool
and i'm just kind of like i guess
because they thought even though like a
lot of the murders obviously strange
could
constrain credulity because it's like
how the [ __ ]
are you gonna find because they go to a
strip club and they kill like 11
ladies dancing or however many ladies
dancing it is and it was there's
like all that kind of thing but it's
like if the you have to really be
committed
to this uh mo if you're gonna
i mean you have to like stalk a person
with the right last name like partridge
or whatever
you have to like kill them in a
particular way and not get caught
and it's just like you know it's it's
not super bowling
it was kind of a comedy though i took it
i took it as a bit of a comedy i think
it was kind of trying to be
right but it wasn't like quite funny
enough yeah
you know what i'm saying it was supposed
to be a comedy i guess it wasn't quite
funny enough so it wasn't like i was
mostly just laughing at
how dumb the cops were that they that it
took them so long
like it took like six mass murders
before they figured out that it was like
the song
you know what i mean and then like the
whole second half of the movie i'm
sitting there going
wait i was like because i could remember
the first 10 things of the song but then
i was like
wait what's 11 and 12 and then i was
just so i was so i started spacing out
because i was like trying to remember
what 11 and 12
so i can try to figure out what the last
two murders were because i couldn't
remember how the song went
but yeah so like i said we'll do some
more christmas movies next week when it
gets closer to holiday
uh this one's on hulu if you somehow
want to watch it i
i wouldn't recommend it but you can't
christmas crime you can if you want to
yeah i've never seen christmas
chronicles
christmas again or like i said if you
want to see a christmas horror movie
see a christmas horror story or krampus
or you know there's like i said there's
a lot of really good christmas horror
movies
um there's a lot of shitty ones too but
there's a lot of good ones that you can
pick from and
you don't really need to watch this one
so i'm just saying all right so uh
that'll do for this matinee
uh we'll probably be back we're not
gonna be back until saturday saturday is
our christmas special
yo yeah yeah that's the next one that we
gotta do um
i guess i can tell you guys because most
of you guys are patrons but
overwhelmingly i should have figured
overwhelmingly what won for the
christmas
special was horrible murders that took
place on christmas
i tried i put like four other things in
there that were like
supernatural or like legend or whatever
like christmas gross ghost stories [ __ ]
like that people were like nope
christmas murders
i was like oh well that's i i i don't
mind doing christmas murders
please call me pookie's calling yeah all
right she wants
she wants to go outside all right so we
will see you guys again
on saturday night for our christmas
special and that'll do it for this step
we'll see you next time bye